bienvenue à tous dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une de l'actualité du
continent le sénégal où une
manifestation de l'opposition a viré à
l'affrontement avec les forces de
l'ordre plusieurs leaders du mouvement
ont été arrêtés nous irons à dakar dès
le début de cette édition
eux aussi manifesté aujourd'hui les
massaï de tanzanie depuis des années ils
dénoncent des expulsions dont ils sont
victimes nous reviendrons sur leur
désarroi face à la perte de leurs terres
et puis enfin nous parlerons de ces
ivoiriens exilés au liberia au ghana ou
en cours au togo depuis des années dans
quelques jours ils perdront leur statut
de réfugié france 24 a rencontré ceux
qui ont fait le choix de rentrer malgré
tout
on va là pour les titres on commence
donc cette édition avec la situation au
sénégal une manifestation de
l'opposition à vire à l'affrontement
avec les forces de l'ordre plusieurs
leaders de l'opposition je vous le
disais en titre ont été arrêtés tous
ceux réclamés à la réhabilitation de
leurs listes électorales a été recalée
par le conseil constitutionnel alors que
les législatives approchent écoutez
elimane dao il est à dakar france 24
deux véritables scènes de guérilla
urbaine aux alentours de la place de la
nation d eux ont éclaté entre forces de
l'ordre et manifestants jets de grenades
lacrymogènes contre des pierres du côté
des manifestants des manifestants qui
réclament la réhabilitation de la liste
des masques à lui bloqué par le conseil
constitutionnel pour la participation
aux législatives de juillet 2020 de son
côté le principal opposant macky sall
ousmane sow quo a dénoncé une entrave à
la liberté de manifestation ce matin
dans une vidéo publiée sur son compte
facebook il a été bloqué chez lui par un
fort dispositif policier
il a également été empêchés d'aller à la
prière du vendredi aden au style on a
posé quelques questions à certains
manifestants je vous propose de les
écouter la démocratie c'est la
démocratie la liberté d'expression n'est
ce pas quelque chose lui qui s'exprime
et de mais il est tout de suite
appréhendez vous quelles raisons ça
c'est un recul démocratique
c'est cette question que je pose le
président pourquoi si elle
les les les élections ou bien quelque
chose ne permettent pas les gens pour
qu'ils vont avoir la liberté pour aller
manifester emakina roi la boue par les
garages interpelle le président macky
sall il faut qu'il laisse les gens aller
librement élection
laissait snacks sont tranquilles tiens
c'est l'espoir de la jeunesse parce que
cette liberté est loin de muguet les
manifestations ont également lieu au sud
du pays à ziguinchor l'opposition
sénégalaise compte ni de camper sur sa
position et veut coûte que coûte
participer à ces élections législatives
autre manifestation au kenya maintenant
d'une ampleur moindre des masaï
originaire de tanzanie se sont
rassemblés à nairobi ils dénoncent les
expulsions dont ils ont été victimes au
cours des dernières semaines 150000
massaï auraient été contraints de
quitter leurs terres à nairobi la
correspondance de bastien andrieu
ils n'étaient pas très nombreux à avoir
répondu à l'appel à manifester ce
vendredi à nairobi une quinzaine tout au
plus et pourtant et bien cela n'a pas
empêché les policiers kényans de
réprimer cette manifestation ils ont
arraché les banderoles en soutien au
masai de tanzanie ils ont tiré des gaz
lacrymogènes et arrêté certains
organisateurs des manifestations
difficile de comprendre exactement
pourquoi mais il semblerait que c'est
parce que la manifestation se rapprocher
de l'ambassade de temps à nier qu'ils
craignaient des troubles à l'ordre
public les organisateurs tenter
d'attirer l'attention internationale sur
ce qu'il se passe de l'autre côté de la
frontière à quelques centaines de
kilomètres de nairobi où 150 mille
messages sont en train d'être expulsés
de leurs terres pour pouvoir créer des
infrastructures touristiques notamment
une nouvelle réserve de chasse au début
du mois de juin des policiers ont fait
irruption sur leurs terres leur ont
demandé de partir il aurait brûlé
certaines maisons ils ont ouvert le feu
quand des masaï ont refusé de quitter
leur village au moins trente personnes
auraient été blessées et un policier
tanzanien auraient été tués durant des
échauffourées selon le gouvernement
tanzanien donc c'est ma sai et bien ne
veulent pas quitter leur terre l'onu
s'est prononcé sur le sujet les experts
des droits de l'homme de l'onu se sont
dit extrêmement inquiet et craignent
qu'il y ait des déplacements forcés ce
qui serait contraire à toutes les lois
internationales sur le sujet
c'est désormais officiel dans quelques
jours les ivoiriens exilés au liberia au
togo ou encore au ghana vont perdre leur
statut de réfugié tous l'avait obtenu
après les violences de 2011 certains
donc fait le choix de rentrer chez eux
mais vous allez le voir l'inquiétude est
toujours là reportages signés samuel
bernard
rentrée après 11 ans d'exil raphaël
retrouve sa soeur pour la seconde fois
depuis son récent retour du tout comme
ses frères et soeurs séparés pendant une
décennie tente de rattraper le temps
perdu
ça va la sape à sa femme qui était là
mais dieu merci qu'il a envie d'y être à
leur aise raphaël est parti en 2011 en
raison de sa proximité avec le camp de
l'ex président laurent gbagbo quand ce
dernier est rentré en juin 2021 il a
commencé à organiser son retour
les gars
ancien policier raphaël attend de
retrouver son statut de fonctionnaire
retour en poste pour les ex membres de
la fonction publique est l'une des
promesses du gouvernement faite aux
anciens exilés
le gouvernement a annoncé d'autres
mesures incitant les réfugiés hors du
pays à rentrer entre autres l'annulation
des impayés fiscaux et la récupération
des biens spoliés pendant la guerre au
total selon les chiffres officiels trois
cent dix mille réfugiés sont rentrés
depuis 2011 pour la majorité venus du
liberia du ghana
que je trouve anne pas que ça ils ont
pâti de guetter le cas et une fois les
réseaux qui a tant fait partie à l'exil
n'existe plus on appelle cette réduction
à quoi nous nous attelons aujourd'hui à
l'évocation de la côte de situation mais
ça coûte aux réfugiés la cessation du
statut de réfugiés pour les ivoiriens
sera effectif le 30 juin il ne fait
cependant pas l'unanimité
selon le nhc air 13 mille réfugiés
ivoiriens sont encore hors du pays pour
sept opposants installés au ghana les
cages apportées par le gouvernement ne
suffisent pas
d'ailleurs mais vraiment
de sécurité
que le haut niveau
le gouvernement ivoirien dit avoir
libéré tous les prisonniers politiques
en côte d'ivoire selon l'opposition il
serait une centaine a encore attendre
leur libération
c'est un incident qui rappelle combien
la situation est tendue ce vendredi à la
frontière entre la république
démocratique du congo et le rwanda un
soldat congolais et abattu il aurait
franchi la zone en tirant vers un poste
au rwandais sa mort a déclenché une
vague de colère sur place sur notre
antenne la réaction ecoutez-la de celles
du ministre rwandais des affaires
étrangères s'était au micro de marc
perelman
cet incident survient dans un contexte
un contexte où il ya eu des discours
deviennent les incitations à la violence
du côté d'une partie du congo et donc
c'était sida est à placer dans la
version contexte c'est un incident qu'on
peut qualifier d qualifié d' incident
isolé parce que les six volets dans un
contexte déterminé
moi c'est
[Musique]
comme ça que
voir des enquêtes où on va on doit
savoir exactement ce qui s'est passé
voici ça faisait partie d un plan b
c'est quand il a pris l'initiative tout
seul mais il faudrait pas le résultat
des enquêtes un entretien retrouver dans
son intégralité toute la journée de
demain sur notre antenne
plus de soixante ans après son
assassinat par des policiers belges
patrice lumumba va enfin avoir une tombe
chez lui au congo le corps du premier
ministre congolais avaient été brûlés
dans de l'acide dans quelques jours à
peine la belgique va donc remettre à ses
enfants ce qu'il en reste une dans une
restitution symbolique mais qui
rappellent encore l'histoire douloureuse
de la belgique avec son ancienne colonie
reportage d'alix le bourdon
depuis plus de trente ans jean paul
cassen des organise régulièrement des
commémorations en l'honneur de patrice
lumumba en ce mois de juin celle ci est
particulière car ce militant c'est que
le seul reste du corps du premier
premier ministre congolais va enfin être
remis à sa famille une dans le fait
qu'on a retrouvé une partie
il mène de patrice le moma
qui est là dedans
c'est déjà une bonne nouvelle parce que
il était dire que le monde avait disparu
en 1961 quelques mois après
l'indépendance de l'ex colonie belge
patrice lumumba est assassiné chargé de
faire disparaître le corps un policier
belge récupère une dans la justice ne
s'en saisira que des décennies plus tard
dans le plus con golais des quartiers
bocéno on s'en réjouit aujourd'hui mais
pour cet écrivain installé en belgique
la justice doit encore faire la lumière
sur cette mort la famille a déposé
plainte il ya plus de dix ans comment ça
se fait que le corps d un type solide
partie de son corps surtout en belgique
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec le corps
de lumumba on attend on sait pas
pourquoi poucet si on pouvait ce qu'on a
ce procès se fait attendre tellement
rama coiffeur à mathon gay depuis 15 ans
se félicite cette restitution mais
voudrait la voir s'inscrire dans une
démarche plus large de réparation c'est
très très bien mais que ça soit pas
juste pour le dent et puis abandonné 7
processus le congo attend beaucoup de
choses parce qu'on a c'est comme si le
congo a raté le départ avec mes genoux
mon bas un avis partagé par cette
militante contre le racisme on a déjà vu
des grands moments comme ça voilà où la
belgique décide de penser à son passé
colonial mais on n'a pas eu de résultats
après dans le vie de tous les jours ou
alors je vais demander à bleus sont
toujours discriminés à cause de la
couleur de peau et à cause des
stéréotypes et des préjugés pur été
créés ou distillé pendant la période
coloniale une période coloniale pour
laquelle le roi des belges a récemment
réitéré ses regrets mais non ces excuses
comme le souhaiteraient certains membres
de la diaspora congolaise de belgique
il fait partie des 500 plus grandes
fortunes de france jacques gauthier
ancien pdg d'assu 2000 est accusé de
traite d'êtres humains de viols et
d'agressions sur mineur il est
actuellement incarcéré en france mais de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée au maroc
quatre femmes l'accusent d'harcèlement
sexuel elles se sont exprimées
aujourd'hui lors d'une conférence de
presse on va écouter l'une d'entre elles
dont jack bouthillier présentée pour les
travailleurs de son entreprise les
hommes travailleurs de son entreprise
comme un trophée si tu le fais rentrer
des contrats il y aura de belles filles
du maroc que je vais vous ramenez
qu'avec son argent elle pouvait acheter
le silence des victimes des témoins vais
voir même dix ans des autorités et des
services de police comme il l'a déclaré
dans un audio et dans des communications
et sont des rumeurs qui sont des fusées
allez on vous emmène au gabon avant de
refermer ce journal après deux ans
d'arrêt complet pour cause de pandémie
de kobe de 19 le parc national de loango
on reprend les observations de gorille
dans l'espoir que cela attire également
les touristes l'ont renversé cher
c'est pisteurs suivent des traces encore
fraîches quand soudain il apparaît à
travers les feuillages
camaia chef de son clan regarde
calmement les intrus avant de se laisser
glisser de sa branche pour entamer sa
sieste quotidienne une attitude presque
nonchalante pour ce gorille au dos
argenté fruit de longues années de
travail pour l'habituer à l'être humain
comme vous le voyez maintenant comme
maya miens massy
il est couché il or là la confiance le
fait de l'amitié légaux les 1100 wikio
notre présence les touristes viennent
d'en voir et ils ont offert vie d'un
bafa nord pour leur propre protection
après deux ans d'arrêt suite à la
pandémie de covile 19 le parc de loango
au gabon recommence à accueillir ses
premiers visiteurs et l'attraction
principale et bien sûr les gorilles
passé une heure avec camaia et sa
famille coûte environ 450 euros des
revenus essentielle pour entretenir les
zones protégées au gabon
le tourisme permet de générer les fonds
nécessaires au fonctionnement du parc
pour protéger les gorilles mais aussi
toutes les autres espèces à travers eux
ils sont une espèce ils sont très
charismatique
miser sur le tourisme pour la
conservation des espèces une stratégie
qui a déjà fait ses preuves en ouganda
et au rwanda où les fonds générés ont
permis de doubler la population de
gorilles en 30 ans
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition tout
de suite l'info revient avec claire
bonnichon quant à nous on se retrouve à
22h40 pour un nouveau journal de
l'afrique a du talent
[Musique]